okay this is Steve Rosenberg and I want
to thank the organizers for giving me
the opportunity to give this talk I'm
going to talk today about the
development of two gene expression tests
for heart transplant rejection and
coronary artery disease that I've been
involved with and we'll take you really
through and it's a tale of two to
product development cycles and that
really covers dis gene discovery
development and then clinical validation
and utility of these tests and clinical
practice just conflicts that I have I'm
currently an employee of cardio DX and I
previously was an employee of a company
called X DX so let's talk a little bit
about peripheral blood gene expression
in molecular diagnostics to sort of
level set everyone so that those of you
who aren't familiar with this can get a
good sense of it so if one's thinking
about the differences between the
utility of gene expression in genetics
in clinical Diagnostics needs to be
remember of course that genetics is
generally static at least to a first
approximation and really reflects
heritable lifetime risk it's very easy
to measure today and at least most of
the studies and in most clinical
situations common genetic variation only
reflects a modest proportion of overall
disease risk from looks at gene
expression on the other hand it
integrates both genetics and
environmental effects such as diet drugs
for the risk factors it's a little bit
more difficult to measure it's more
subjective sampling and methyl auditable
challenges and has an advantage because
it's all some time dependent it monitors
what's going on today with you and hence
it has the possibility of monitoring
disease progression
one of those issues is that it is a
continuous measure wide variety of to
expression values possible rather than
discrete value in your genetics and
we'll talk about two examples of blood
based multi gene expression tests today
so if we look specifically at the
peripheral blood gene expression as a
window on the immune system one can
imagine that in the extracellular fluid
in blood plasma or serum there are a lot
of potential biomarkers including DNA
micro RNAs protein markers these can be
derived data from circulating cells or
other tissues such as the endothelial
cell wall has been smooth muscle cells
or other organs even including a
microbiome well we'll be focusing on
today or peripheral blood cells which
really represent a very complex mixture
of cell lineages and specific cell types
starting from grammaticality precursors
all the way to terminally differentiated
cells like platelets or red blood cells
and with respect to gene expression each
of these cell types and lineage
subpopulations have different patterns
of gene expression the patterns are
dynamic and they respond to both the
ingrained genetics as well as
environmental factors including
pathological conditions and with respect
to pathological conditions one can see
variations in both proportions of cells
distributions of lineages from
precursors all the way to terminally
differentiated as well as specific gene
expression patterns within a particular
kind of cell type and lastly an
important point to recognize is that if
you have an immune disorder changes in
peripheral blood gene expression may
actually be a direct reflection of an
immune response or they can be an
indirect reflection of the response of
those circulating cells to a cellular
partition insult so now let's talk about
the first example I'll cover today that
is the development of a blood-based two
expressions for four
planet projection so the first heart
print transplant was done about 50 years
ago now and limitations in the organ
supply still have prevented ideological
matching for donors and recipients for
example they're only about 2,000
translating stone per year in the US
currently there's three drug
immunosuppressive therapy for these
patients once they've been transplanted
and the five-year survival is very good
it's over seventy percent of the
patients or rejection free but longer
term survival is often compromised
because they are on this long-term
immunosuppression leading to infections
and longer terms lymphomas in bikinis
and the way you monitor rejection in
these patients is by what's called an
endomyocardial biopsy which is an
invasive procedure that's done up to 12
times in the first year post transplant
it's an invasive procedure there are
sampling issues because it ends up only
sampling a specific location in Maya
premium and depending on which
pathologist and at which time interprets
it image you can get different results a
multicenter study was started now dozen
years ago or so at eight major
transplant centers and what was obtained
in this study were blood samples that
mononuclear cells a subset of all log
cells in the blood as well as the
results from an end of myocardial biopsy
clinical data on medications and
outcomes and the total of six hundred
and thirty patients roughly speaking
you're enrolled and about five thousand
samples obtained this was by far the
largest study looking at genomic
information and Transplant that have
been done some of the challenges with
using an amount of cardio biopsy as a
gold standard in the development of the
tests are listed on this slide so the
transplant pathologists scale that was
originally developed it's really based
on the appearance of infiltrates into my
accordion and not really based on a
linear
atonic increasing disease disease
severity what is agreed is that grade 3
a rejection now call to our is really
the threshold for treatment the bull s
IV steroids to reduce the likelihood of
transplant rejection with hemodynamic
compromise where the heart muscle no
longer pumps effectively in the car go
study three very experienced transplant
pathologists examined over 800 samples
and a paper they published which I'll
refer to later they showed there was a
very limited concordance between them
this then illustrates a common problem
you with an imperfect gold standard
which has both statistical and clinical
imports so in this study the subsequent
work to defining what a rejection was
was limited to at least two pathologists
out of 4 total reads identifying a
sample or patient sample as grade 3 day
or greater rejection and this as I
mentioned is a real challenge for
developing a test with this is a gold
standard so the overall scheme for the
discovery and development is complex I
mean shown on the next slide
diagrammatically really break it up into
three parts initially there were
microarray studies that were done this
was actually a custom microarray before
the wide availability of large-scale
whole transcriptome arrays and also
because of limitations of those arrays
literature and bioinformatics were also
used about 300 patient samples were
subjected to these micro arrays and from
that about a hundred genes and about 150
from the literature would pull together
as a gene discovery group where they had
shown statistical significance in
separating people with three a rejection
from those who do not
these array-based genes were then
converted to PCR assays and that allows
were then looked at in an additional 150
samples yielding about 68 candidate
genes these genes were then put together
using a statistical method to construct
what are known as meta genes where the
correlation structure of the gene
expression data was used to reduce the
dimensionality this then yield at about
20 meta genes that were used along with
the individual genes in algorithm
development and this finally led to an
11 gene classifier you could estimate
the performance of that classifier among
the patient samples that was used to
develop it but the much more rigorous
way in way that's early required is to
use an independent validation set and
that's what was done subsequently the
next slide really covers what I just
said specifically with respect to the
algorithm development piece the 68 genes
and 20 meta genes were used in algorithm
development a number of different
statistical methods were used including
logistic regression random forests and
linear discriminant analysis the final
algorithm was developed with lda as it's
known it's the most rigorous method for
estimating performance by
cross-validation and we use this method
then to both select terms and weights
and also to add additional terms and see
whether adding additional genes or terms
would improve the performance the actual
biological basis of the algorithms is
shown on this slide where you see terms
which one of all the steroid
responsiveness steroids are using the
treatment in the disease platelets
hematopoiesis probably reflecting the
fact that the lineage has change in this
setting when you have transplant
rejection and
Merrow stress and then there are a
number of genes involved in the
activation of T cells which are really
the marker and the hallmark of
transplant rejection so there was not
required that these genes have known
functions which are important in
transplant and obviously is a useful
thing to get support for such a toast
downstream so for validation there was
first a primary validation set where the
patients were enriched for rejection
samples 63 total patients that were
completely naive too many of the
development in discovery work and 31
rejections and 32 quiescent patients and
then a secondary validation in an
additional larger set of independent
samples and this was then coupled with a
pre-specified analysis planned and a
score threshold when you look on the
next slide where we have the primary
endpoint this is by ROC analysis where
you plot the sensitivity or true
positives vs 1 minus the specificity of
false positive rates and one measures
the area under the curve where a test
which is no better than mandame falls
along the diagonal or has an area of
point 5 and in this case the area under
the curve auc was point 7 too much
better than random sensitivity of
eighty-four percent quite good rather
modest specificity and it turned out
that the time post transplant when
steroids are being weaned by is a large
confounding variable in this study and
when one looks at performance later post
transplant in fact performance of the
test is considerably better and higher
thresholds can be used and that's
illustrated here where we see the
original validation data with all
patients post transplant on left then a
you see a point 72 and if you look at
either six months or 12 months post
transplant you see the AMC goes up
significantly to point a 2.86
all of these results however are
challenged because of the uncertainty
and the true rejection status of the
patients due to the complexities and
incredible biopsy so in order to look at
a less ambiguous endpoint a second study
called the image study was started in
this study about 600 patients from six
months to five years post transplant
we're in Logan 13 centers and they were
randomized to either gene expression
testing as their major mode of care or
endomyocardial biopsy so as a
head-to-head study comparing these two
the primary endpoint was non inferiority
for the gene expression test in terms of
patient outcomes we're here we're
looking at death ree transplantation or
rejection with hemodynamic compromise as
the primary endpoints and the secondary
endpoint where was examined whether
there was a difference of number of
biopsies performed so here we have a
much less ambiguous endpoint in one
which is clinically obviously clearly
relevant so the next slide shows the
patient flow that turned out this was a
relatively difficult study to roll
starting with about 3,000 patients about
1,200 were invited to participate
finally that 600 of those were excluded
so we ended up with 602 patients
enrolled so that it raises some
questions about whether this population
is overall representative of the entire
transplant population or not and then
you'll see at the end it looks like it
probably is but it's not so clear these
patients were then randomized 297 in
each group and it was quite good follow
up with two-year follow-up looking at
the endpoints I mentioned earlier so
what happened so if we look at the next
slide while we can show and see is that
in the upper panel where it's looking at
events as a function of time what woman
sees is that overall the event rates
which were fifteen percent over two
years were no different between the
myocardial and Amon Carter biopsy plays
care
gene expression base care and in fact
survival curve which is shown on bottom
also shows no significant difference but
I don't show here but was a secondary
endpoint was that the number of biopsies
was reduced by two-thirds in the gene
expression based thorne so they're very
nice flooding and really this is the
only study which has been done where a
randomized controlled and blinded study
was performed comparing gene expression
based testing in any really clinical
indication with standard of care looking
at long-term outcomes and the key
references for this work are shown here
the first one being the pathology work I
mentioned at the beginning the second is
the discovery development and validation
of the expression test and the last is
the image study results published in the
New England Journal meant three years
ago so we're going to switch gears now
from heart transplant rejection to a
gene expression tennis for obstructive
coronary artery disease as I mentioned
earlier there only a couple of thousand
transplant patients seen each year for
heart transplants there are millions of
people who have symptoms subjective
suggestive of obstructive coronary
artery disease who are seen by
physicians each year and that's why this
tennis then was developed so they look
on the next slide why didn't we think
that such a test was possible well it's
non based on work originally published
by russell ross and others that
inflammation is a key driver in the
development of atherosclerosis other
workers have shown that if you look in
the disease best of all she changes in
gene expression and people who have
ethnos courses or coronary artery
disease um multiple groups have shown
that the example I just went through is
a good example of changes in peripheral
blood gene expression that correlate
with inflammatory and immune mediated
disorders and hence we ask the question
can gene expression and circulating
cells reflect the presence of
coronary artery disease in the vessel
wall well why would you want to do this
aren't or other ways to do this well it
turns out in a landmark paper which was
published on 2010 in romanian journal
where the national catholic data
registry was interrogating 400,000
patients who had been sent for elective
coronary angiography turns out only
little less than forty percent of them
thirty-eight percent in his study and in
fact been shown to have obstructive
disease in fact that any need to be in
counselor at all so more than half these
patients did not need to have an
invasive procedure and this was despite
the fact that over eighty percent of
them had received non-invasive imaging
tests or diagnostic tests prior to the
referral to catheterization so clear and
unmet need we can do better than this so
in the development of this coronary
artery disease gene expression scored on
multiple independent cohorts were used
the new discovery first phase
development second phase and algorithm
valuation third phase we're in the
initial part of the study then
single-center cohorts were used that
word retrospective and then prospective
multicenter studies were used
subsequently to end up with the
development of validation of the test
initial gene discovery was done on a
small set of microarrays in this cases
are not custom arrays but ones from
agilent about 50 candidate genes were
identified an additional fifty six were
taken from the comb from the literature
RT pcr assays were then developed these
were then tested and subsequent
independent cohorts one from on the same
german cohort and another from instead
of samples from a registry at duke
called katja and what was found based on
these results are shown on the next
slide where what we've plotted are the
significance of the gene based on pcr
assays in
Duke captain cohort versus that in the
German cohort and what you can see is
there is a group of genes which are
found in the lower left which are not
significant either one and a total of
twenty-seven out of 106 in fact was
significant in both cohorts if
everything was perfect everybody being
on the diagonal but in fact the Duke
cohort this one's using whole blood and
in the secret cohort they were using
just see Petey's tubes so there are
additional genes present and Duke cohort
which are more significant which are
those significant in cburg or even more
significant clear so that um was one of
the observations made second observation
made in this study was in caption
microarrays was that patients who had
diabetes in fact and Jeff different
genes dysregulated if they had coronary
artery disease compared to those without
just like in the previous slide if the
same genes were just regulated in both
courts you would see genes along the
diagonal we see here is no genes of
significance between both diabetics and
non-diabetics and independent groups of
genes in fact for diabetics they're
largely from natural killer cells and
are largely driven by neutrophil genes
in the non-diabetics so this led us then
to limit subsequent test development to
non-diabetic patients we then enrolled a
multicenter study called predict eric
topol and skips as the p line and this
was a cath lab population where patients
who were had already been clinically
referred for an invasive angiogram after
clinic visits and possible non-invasive
testing or screened enrolled and a large
amount of clinical data was obtained
research blood samples were obtained and
then they went on and they're invasive
angiogram so what hadn't is studied in
was paired result of an invasive
angiogram a picture of these patients
coronary arteries as well as blood
samples the angiograms were then read in
a poor laboratory by a computerized
method called quantitative coronary
angiography to reduce variation
and RNA was extracted from the blood
samples so in the gene discovery phase
micro arrays were completed on about 400
patients we found the largest express
this affects overall in gene expression
to be due to the patient's age they cell
tower proportions we had complete cell
counts and all expansions about
diabetics in their status so we limited
this to non-diabetics we derived
sex-specific age-dependent scenes for
coronary disease risk and we picked 113
genes from the micro reins to be
measured by pcr in an independent cohort
we use the similar approach that was we
talked about with respect to the heart
transplant rejection where we use meta
genes in this case we use ratios meta
genes to get a general and cell
type-specific normalization and the
method of choice for algun development
here was logistic progression where we
used Ridge regression finally to get
final wings this was described in a
paper that was published a couple years
ago um in terms of microarray work the
initial studies from the seeburg and
catch and discovery courts for
heterogeneous in terms of the methods of
RNA extraction used the kind of tubes
there where the blood was obtained in in
one case cpt tubes in another case hold
blood packaging tubes the case control
definitions were subtly different as
were the inclusion criteria so this was
the possible source of variation and
possible confounding variables he then
went on to extend and discovery work to
the predicts thing where we had in the
meantime develop an automated and very
reproducible robotic method for RNA
extraction from whole blood we use
quantitative coronary angiography to
define case-control status and we use a
paired design where the sets of cases
and controls that were matched with
respect to age and sex where in fact one
on the same microarray
chimps and finally this was restricted
only to non-diabetics and as you can see
on this slide whereas we had a modest
number of genes in the original to
single center cohorts 500 roughly in
2,400 in this last multicenter derived
cohort where we had made these process
improvements same size cohort when we
were getting two and a half to three
times as many genes as significant
almost 6,000 so we used all of these
data with with a bias towards that last
predict set to derive these 113 genes
which were then I developed piecing our
assays for and these would then run on
an independent set of 640 patients from
the predicted study to use in the
development of the final algorithm one
of the things that we found in this data
set was that as we had suspected there
were quite significant differences
between men and women on what we showed
here is the percentage of patients women
in red then in blue that either no
significant coronary disease clean
coronaries on the left and what you can
see is almost forty percent of the women
have no detectable disease and about
twenty percent of men and conversely
when we looked at obstructive coronary
disease you know fifty percent
blockheads or stenosis in any major
coronary artery only one in five women
had such a blockage whereas it was
almost half with men so this clearly
said that you needed different kinds of
effects to measure in the two genders so
I've gone through this already once we
use that data than to drive sex specific
age dependencies for coronary disease
risk we use the microarray data that was
in run on 113 jeans as rt-pcr to develop
this large matrix of 113 genes by six
hundred forty patients to then on news
as the algorithm development set
I'm using a number of different
statistical methods including clustering
as well as well variety of correlation
data and using some biological input as
well we derive meta genes meta-gene
ratios were used to then come up with
potential terms and then logistic
regression was used in a forward
stepwise manner to pick the terms that
were significant on top of the age and
sex depended coronary disease risk
factors so what we ended up with then
was an algorithm with 23 genes in it and
it contains three kinds of terms the
first is the gender specific age
dependent coronary disease risk
functions second or because each cell
type within all the lineages on in blood
has a distinct gene expression pattern
and in fact you can separate the gene
expression patterns in cells by cell
types pretty readily on there we use
that to in fact be able to essentially
count specific kinds of cells like
natural killer cells for example in the
blood and have terms that reflect ratios
of cell types and finally we have genes
which are up or down regulated within a
given cell type as a possible kind of
term so if we look at the underlying
biology behind some of these terms from
the genes in the algorithm are shown
here in the upper left you see a group
of genes including castes 5 mile 18
receptor-associated protein that are
involved in apoptosis inflammatory cell
signaling on the lower left or group of
genes which are upregulated with
response to oxidative damage oxidized
LDL being a driver of atherosclerosis as
well as response to cellular necrosis we
see genes there represent specific cell
types namely those for t-cells and
b-cells and finally another set of genes
on the lower right which are
specifically expressed in the innate
immune response and specifically
upregulated in natural killer cells
so once we had this algorithm finalized
locked what did the validation studies
look like in fact we ran two sequential
validation studies in two different
populations the first study was an
extension of predict where we use the an
independent cohort of patients from the
same overall study and we developed the
algorithm in this is a prospective
multicenter and blinded study all
non-diabetics 39 sites here in the US
and quantitative coronary angiography my
Alexandra Lansky is clearly yell on was
wrong on all the patients patients were
either had symptoms suggestive
obstructive coronary disease or they
were asymptomatic but had a number of
risk factors leading them to have being
referred for invasive coronary
angiography they were all non-diabetic
and they could never had a prior heart
attack or vascularization / teenager
because you wouldn't need to test then
to tell whether it had coronary disease
um when we looked at this overall
population and the validation study was
published in 2010 in the annals internal
medicine we found that thirty-seven
percent of the patients predict and
obstructive disease essentially the same
as the thirty-eight percent that was
found in large and CD or study and this
really suggested that this relatively
small population of about 500 patients
that we use for validation really was
typical as compared to this much larger
group so we then set out a prospective
validation study plan we had a locked
algorithm as I mentioned and the
independent cohort of patients than 525
in total now we had defined the case
control definition as fifty percent
stenosis or greater in a major coronary
artery in at least one vessel and that
represented about thirty-seven percent
of the patients in this group we locked
all the clinical data and completed it
on-site monitoring or cleaning good
clinical practices and all the rt-pcr we
had predefined quality control metrics
for the PCR
Anna predefined analysis plan the
primary endpoint was ROC analysis could
you distinguish cases from controls
treating the disease as binary which in
fact it is not as we'll talk about later
and the other endpoints focused in on
seeing whether the gene expression data
would add to clinical factors which can
be used to estimate risk of obstructive
coronary disease and all of this is done
by an external statistical group led by
Nick short and scripts so what happens
on the primary endpoint shown here in
roc curve is sensitivity versus when my
specificity you seen area under the
curve of point 70 much better than
random which was point five highly
statistically significant and
importantly was independently
significant in both men and women in
this next slide we asked whether the
gene expression score would add to
clinical factors the clinical algorithm
here is one that uses age sex and the
kind of chest pain the patients have
which at least a min is a very good
indicator of whether you have a likely
to have obstructive coronary disease and
what we can show here is by roc analysis
that the gene expression score did add
to clinical factors in a statistically
significant way this is a highly
rigorous method for seeing whether
you're adding value to be pre-existing
classifier and if you then look at the
percentage of patients who have
obstructive see ad and as a function of
the gene expression score which is
reported under 12 40 scale when you see
here in a logistic analysis is that
there's a nice overall dynamic range
from less than ten percent all the way
up to almost eighty percent for this
group and at a threshold of twenty
percent likelihood about a third of the
patients fall below that threshold where
the sensitivity and negative predictive
value of the chest in this patient
population who had already been referred
for coronary angiography
um his thirty-seven percent so a
significant fraction of the patients in
turn were found in a low-risk group an
additional factor which turned out to be
quite fascinating what you found was
shown in this slide where we plot on the
vertical axis the test score and on the
x axis we have the max percent stenosis
to another measure of overall disease
severity or burden what you can see is
that even among those patients who have
do not represent cases that have less
than fifty percent stenosis with three
barns general s if you have no
detectable coronary disease you have the
lowest average score and that continues
to increase even with not obstructive
disease and continues to go up beyond
that with a single Viet vessel disease
or multi vessel disease so despite the
fact that we're treating this clinically
as a case-control fifty percent or
greater you should go on and potentially
have an angiogram in fact the biology
tells you this is in fact a continuous
variable and the more disease about the
higher your score is so what are the
limitations of this particular thing
well they're really worth three first in
predict we had a group of patients who
had already been referred for coronary
angiography and the question was raised
well what happens at a lower risk
population which is really where this
test would be intended to be used second
of all if you want to use this test as
in rule out test for eliminating
downstream procedures invasive than
otherwise you really need to know
whether it's safe to do so when you need
patient outcomes and events and finally
there's really no comparison in this
study to usual care which is done with a
non-invasive imaging method primarily
consisting you have no clear perfusion
imaging of myocardial perfusion imaging
so we went on to a second validation
study in the compass trial which I'll
take you through now on to try and
answer these questions and we also had
one-year follow-up data on and then some
safety from the predicts that
so compass we looked at an independent
validation of this test again nice table
symptomatic patients only and in this
case they've been referred to
non-invasive imaging specifically
myocardial perfusion imaging and really
that represents an intended use
population for such as secondary
endpoint was to evaluate the
head-to-head comparison of MPR
performance in the real world setting
versus two gene expression scored
another prospective multicenter blinded
study this case 19 sites here in the US
that's 130 patients number of core
laboratories we used and an independent
academic steering committee led by greg
thomas was former president of the
American Society of nuclear cardiology
led the study as i mentioned symptomatic
patients non-diabetics again they
couldn't have known obstructive disease
or a prior heart attacks where
revascularization so here's the study
design chest pain patients were referred
for myocardial perfusion imaging they
could have typical very typical symptoms
gene expression score a blood sample was
then obtained and then their routine
stress myocardial perfusion imaging
study was run if that study was positive
and it was clinically indicated they
went on to invasive in geography the mom
was a novel factor in this test was that
a theme myocardial perfusion imaging
study was negative and they normally
would not have any further workup a CT
angiogram was obtained the reason for
doing this was that we would then have
gold standard anatomical data on every
patient in the study independent of
whether their MP I was positive or
negative we then used these anatomical
data and took them to court laboratories
take out variation between individual
readers the invasive angiograms were
then read by quantitative coronary
angiography as a predict CT angiogram
were read by two independent CTA core
lab readers led by the Lord for us and
in the case of MPI we did the original
interpreter
based on the on-site weeds and then we
also had core lab interpretation of
those data just to make sure that we
were not getting fooled by the NPI site
grid results so what did the patient
flow look like we had five hundred and
thirty-seven patients enrolled we needed
to have a myocardial perfusion image we
need to have a gene expression score and
we needed to have either a CT angiogram
or and in based on the integrand for
every patient your door can qualify well
you can see here is of the 537 patients
that a hundred did not have the CTA
those were patients with negative
myocardial perfusion zimage declined to
have a CT angiogram you're a few where
the NPI images were not appropriate for
reading and only three we do not have a
gene expression score so 437 thirty-one
patients were valuable that had both NPI
GS and called standard um interestingly
no almost ninety percent of them at
negative NP is so this was quite a low
risk population only 48 of positive
MPI's if you look then on the upper part
of the curve of the 383 with negative
MPI's almost all of them at sinking
angiograms but a significant fraction
then went on to CAF mac matter of fact a
total of forty-six of the cases with
fifty percent of greater stenosis and in
fact negative myocardial perfusion
imaging studies at study entry those who
are positive for mpi a little more
kaplan went directly to Kenneth and
about a third of them in fact had
obstructive disease women looked at the
gold standard anatomical theta so a lot
of patients with negative and P I scams
if you look over all at the study and
this summarizes the case control status
in the negative and positive + p9y
groups or you can see is that if you had
a negative NPI almost ninety percent of
the patients were
on did not have obstructive disease and
only twelve percent did but that twelve
percent represents significant about
two-thirds of the cases whereas since
only eleven percent of positive scans
although the percentage is thirty-five
percent that represents a minority of
cases Olympian lose another and poor
sensitivity in this thing but the
diagnostic Gill that calf was
thirty-five percent with a positive NPI
skin which was similar to a lot of seen
in in CDR study i mentioned to you
earlier so if one looks at roc analysis
then comparing myocardial perfusion
imaging in this study come with the gene
expression score you've seen this kind
of graft before well you can see is that
here's the dash line represent manda NP
i sight read was a little better
demandin point 59 AUC core lab went up a
little bit 2.63 but the gene expressions
for had an area under the curve of point
79 a bit better than what was seen in
the predict study where was point 70 and
in fact I'll you know performed mpi by
roc analysis in this study when then
compares the gene expression score to a
couple of different clinical factor
algorithms following along the lines of
what was done and predict here we show
that the gene expression score is in
fact superior to either diamond forester
or another score the Maurice score in
this population which is lower risk so
one of the things too that's important
remember in this analysis is that
historically when non-invasive imaging
studies have been done they've been
focused on patient populations who have
been referred to the cath lab to have an
invasive angiogram because that's your
gold standard and those who did not get
referred clinically in fact we're not
booked so in a recent meta-analysis
looking at that referral biased
population sensitivity of mpi was
eighty-one percent recent estimates show
that there's about an Eightfold to
10-fold referral bias of the likelihood
of having invasive angiography if you
have a positive versus a negative
p i scan and if you correct this using
some known statistical methods the
sensitivity for mpi drops from about
eighty percent to thirty-five percent
specificity goes up to about ninety four
percent these results are very similar
to what we saw in the compass study in
compass referral bias ins minimized
because everyone with an NPI scan with
his positive or negative was referred
for further evaluation to get a gold
standard view of their anatomy and
remember in the core lab results
encompass the sensitivity was thirty-six
percent and specificity was 90 so if we
look over all the validation study
results in comparing and encompass what
you see comparing the gene expression
score with Saito correlogram mpi you see
high sensitivity to the gene expression
score modest the low sensitivity from
MPI modest specificity from the gene
expression score a decree specified
threshold of 15 but high specificity
from MPI negative predictive value very
good 96% this population is lower
disease prevalence to expect that to be
higher than what was interpreted and
also superior to what Messina API which
has a higher positive predictive value
but if you look at overall diagnostic
accuracy as measured by the ROC analysis
in gene expression school in superior so
one way to look at all of this is to
look at every patient in the study this
side doesn't do we produce very well but
what we show here is core laboratory mpr
result either positive or neg the
jiggering to our separate points as a
function of the gene expression score on
the x-axis and the points each point
represents an individual patient with
either essentially no coronary disease
non obstructive disease or a case
obstructive disease what you can see is
that the vast majority of patients with
low scores and a pre-specified of
threshold fifth kingdoms used in this
study have very little disease deny and
a six percent negative predictive value
speaks to that and as you go up in score
the amount of disease goes up and you
can see that in fact if you have both
high score over 28 and a positive
nuclear perfusion scan about seventy
percent of those patients have
obstructive disease and almost all of
them have some measurable disease so
this slide illustrates two things that
in fact myocardial perfusion imaging and
the gene expressions for are somewhat
complementary but if you're interested
in the group of patients don't of
disease gene expression score doesn't
much better idea of both identifying
them and being highly sensitive to the
presence of obstructive disease so if we
looked at it in some at both the
predicting compass validation studies
you can see that I got very concordant
data and encompass and predict the
sensitivities and the mid high 80s
specificity or modest about fifty
percent negative predictive value was
ninety-six percent in compass 83 and
predict and that reflects the decreased
prevalence in calmness versus predict
last thing to remember about this study
was well what happens the jennxpenn
score relative to usual care namely my
credit perfusion imaging and in this
case gene expression for outperform that
both either site we had record that
print so we went and then look to safety
and outcomes what happens we've answered
the first question what happens in a
population of lower risk the gene
expression score seemed to perform well
there what about safety in terms of
patients so we followed patients for one
year and predict and six months
encompass and if you look at this
clinical diagram which is shown on this
slide which is based on the compass data
if you chuck the patients who in scores
of less than 15 rather 96% negative
particular value
was the case that represented almost
half the patients forty-six percent
crusaders she's percent of the patients
in the study and you would say well
those might not need any further testing
we then take those who have elevated
scores and have another test to further
stratify them if they had my credit
perfusion scan most of those would be
negative they wouldn't have further
testing and a small fraction would go on
to the cath lab and in this case you
would enrich the population of the cath
lab because none of these patients
affair we're at low scores would go on
to count you would increase the yelda
capped almost fifty percent in order to
do something like this and the clinic
you need to know that these patients
were ruled out with low scores in fact
don't have any adverse events going
forward so when we've Illustrated on
this slide is looking at low versus hi
gene expression scores as a function
whether the patients had either
revascularisation with a month or later
we've a sensation or major adverse
cardiovascular events namely non-fatal
myocardial infarctions strokes are all
cause mortality well you can see is that
in the column to the left in the early
revascularization on less than only one
actually the patient's ya head of 199 in
that crew had a revascularisation within
a month whereas those that group about
230 patients who had elevated scorns the
rate of revenge sensation was 20 times
as high 10 and a half percent and one
lucked out six months at late
revitalization and adverse events there
were none in the low score group and all
of the events 3 in this case we're in
high school group a similar pattern is
shown in the predict group with longer
follow-up there's a three-fold increase
in earlier vascularization for those
patients higher scores versus low scores
and about a two and a half fold increase
in the event ring for those who have
elevated score versus low scores over
in 12 months if one looks at whether the
gene expression score as a continuous
variable was associated with increased
event likelihood it was in both studies
in a statistically significant way so to
summarize these data the coronary
disease and especially tests developed
through a series of microarray and
rt-pcr studies test validation was
accomplished in two multicenter studies
primary role of such a test is to rule
out a coronary disease etiology patients
so that they can then have their
symptoms that investigated other
possible causes the high negative
predictive value in the compass 30 and
consists in sensitivity in both studies
enables patients to be ruled out with a
high degree of safety and certainty and
that was reiterated because there were
low scores had little or no events and
we followed up without subsequent
referrals to cardiology or angiography
the year a series of papers published
you know on the coronary disease work
and those are some maroons there I want
to acknowledge all my colleagues at both
X DX and all the investigators from both
the cargo and image studies colleagues a
cardio DX and the investigators in
predicting compass especially pilcrow
else so I boris and Eric Topol as well
as Alexander Lansky Thomas Pearson and
especially the compost in debate with
you Craig Thomas and overall then to
summarize what I've tried to show you
today is the development of two blood
basting expression assays for heart
transplant rejection obstructive
coronary disease that been discovered
developed and validated in multicenter
complaints Eric significant limitations
of where the current standards of care
is called standards in test development
in order to really get at clinical use
one really needs to then look at
outcomes which we're done in both cases
the high-throughput genomic technologies
used to originally identified genes in
these cases create a now well-known
statistical issues about multiple
testing these can be mitigated using
sequential independent cohorts or
essentially one is getting rid of the
noise and hopefully following the true
signals because the noise will randomize
in addition court and the true signals
were going to come through you really
need to show comparison to usual care to
show that the genomic tests are
favorable this can be done either in a
prospective randomized manner as was
done in the image study and a single
head-to-head comparison as was done in
compass I think with that I'll stop and
I'm happy to take questions
so I'm sure I am very clear in my talks
but not so clear that there are in any
questions
you
you
well as there don't appear to be any
questions perhaps we should finish this
session Don ok